the jurogan experience like so many
things that terence mckenna
said it's both true and untrue i think
it's
untrue in a literal sense but very true
in a poetic sense because
the historical cultural context of a
drug
is part of what you bring to that drug
experience the molecule
does not contain information the
ketamine molecule
does not bring an experience to you that
is something that is generated in your
brain by your
consciousness and so if you have a new
substance
that has no cultural associations
then maybe it was like that so you don't
have expectations
you don't have expectations right that's
a big part of it isn't it
it's a huge part of it yeah yeah yeah i
mean i
i made a piece in the new season of my
show about
um five meow dmt containing toad venom
um and there's a big controversy in the
toad venom community which believe it or
not is a
community and they are
purists are they friends with the
opiophiles
oh definitely not no no they don't like
the opiophiles
so what does the venom community think
they think
that this venom has some spiritual
component
derived from its association with the
toad that makes it better than synthetic
5-meo dmt
now i've analyzed several samples of
toad venom
and before 5-meo dmt was made illegal in
the united states
and in terms of what you find if you you
know inject it into a mass spectrometer
5-meo dmt is the only psychedelic that's
present
in some samples there might be trace
quantities of another psychedelic called
bufotenin
but it's a miniscule amount of a less
potent
molecule so predominantly you have five
immunodmt which is
likely the strongest naturally occurring
serotonergic psychedelic
and for conservation purposes
it's necessary that people stop milking
toads because
it's become too popular mike tyson's
talking about it all the time
i mean and it's like it sounds
ridiculous like mike tyson could have
an effect on um conservation
but if a celebrity says they like
something that can have
a tangible effect on the environment i
know people who have toads
for that very reason because mike tyson
talked about those toads
now they have toads and they milk these
toads
oh yeah i mean me too i i talked with a
billionaire
who flew a private jet full of toads to
greece to create a private
toad sanctuary wow and i saw photos wow
how many toads has he got
didn't the photos didn't look like that
many didn't look like a jet full
5meo dmt does not strike me as something
that you'd want to do a lot
it's so terrifying that's probably the
most terrifying experience i've ever had
on psychedelics because i
cease to exist like it's the the one
drug where i i feel like when i took it
i wasn't there anymore
i i was gone until i came back
like i felt like i didn't have thoughts
i didn't have
i i knew i knew i was experiencing
the 5vo dmt realm or whatever it was
but i didn't there was no context
in terms of i didn't realize i'm on my
couch sitting at home like i was gone
i was gone there's no visuals it was
just this
white sort of pixelated like
grayish white gone world
you know and it was terrifying because
it felt like death it was the one thing
that felt the most
like oh my god like now now i don't
know i'm not here anymore but coming
back from it
i think it was very valuable like as i
was returning
i remember thinking so much about
so much about the the [ __ ] way in
which i talk i remember thinking that
like god he's like
so much of the way i would communicate
was not just me trying to get my
thoughts across
but me trying to say things in a way
that would be impressive
or in a way that would be flowery
or you know try to make it look like i
was more intelligent than i was or
whatever but i remember like remembering
that like really clearly
like well i kind of clean up the way i
talk so i'm full of [ __ ]
like thinking that as i was as i was
trying to figure out
how i was going to describe this
experience
i was realizing as i was thinking like
god i gotta figure out how to describe
this like
boy i talk like i'm full of [ __ ] like
so there was value in that but i did it
a few times
i think i did it three times but it was
uh terrifying
every time terrifying like while you're
gone like why you slip away
i remember just thinking like oh this is
not good this is not good like you feel
like
oh my god i [ __ ] up like i really died
i really i really stopped being here and
it also makes you think like
maybe this is going to the light maybe
this is what they talk about
when they talk about going to the light
when you die like maybe you're having
this kind of experience
because it's really disturbing but then
pretty peaceful when it's over
like uh i felt pretty good when it came
back but the concept of giving away
all of my control of reality like that
for some reason nndmt doesn't scare me
as much
it's a totally different drug yeah yeah
experientially chemically it's you know
silicon is closer to dmt than five meow
dmt is
mushrooms are closer chemically speaking
yeah and
yeah i think that it defies description
in a different way than other
psychedelic experiences do with
something like dmt
it's difficult to describe because
there's such an abundance of imagery and
thoughts and dissociations
that it's extremely difficult to
communicate that to someone
with five meow dmt there's nothing and
that's also difficult to communicate
that you white out and there is an
absence of everything completely do you
find it terrifying
i have found it terrifying yes it's it's
very i've you know i have
i had a very profound experience with it
in 2017
and i have no real desire to use it
again yeah that's my thought too it's
like i'm not going back there
i'll go back to nn dmt
i'll go back to that oh me too because
it's just a different
drug entirely and i think that
dmt can be integrated into a normal life
much more easily than five meow dmt
actually
i credit dmt with like sort of i talked
about the
sort of covet denial that i had at the
beginning of the pandemic where i was
you know i can't stop making my tv show
we're all gonna get it anyway we can't
just stop
working we can't shut down the world we
can't stop flying
and then i smoked dmt and had this um
image of m.c escher's angels and
demons but instead of angels and demons
it was pangolins and horseshoe bats
and came out of it and and thought
uh of course i feel horrible of course
this is depressing and confusing this is
actually
one of the worst things that has
happened in my lifetime and i just have
to accept it now
and i felt so much more at peace it just
stripped away the denial
and and i could just say all right this
is happening and so you were just
wrestling with the reality of having to
shut down
yeah and kind of i resented some other
people on my team who in retrospect were
behaving in a way that was completely
rational where i was thinking like oh
come on
we're not going to go on this shoot
really but
but they were right and i was wrong and
i had to stop catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience